okay today I'm going to talk to you
about fuel cells a fuel cell is an
electrical cell that when supplied with
a fuel and oxygen uses energy from the
reaction between them to generate
electricity so remember the name of the
game is generating electricity now this
is an equation to show the reaction that
goes on in a hydrogen oxygen fuel cell
so we could see that we have hydrogen
oxygen reacting together to produce just
water and also enough energy to generate
electricity now so why why do we need to
learn learn about fuel cells no the
reason is at the moment a lot of our
electricity comes from burning fossil
fuels so the t-33 types of fossil fuels
coal oil and natural gas now the problem
with this is the waste products that are
produced when we burn these so carbon
dioxide co2 produces global warming now
what that means is it actually absorbs
some of the thermal energy infrared
radiation from the Sun and it causes
global temperatures to rise around the
world and this can melt the ice caps
causing the sea levels to rise we also
produce this thing called carbon
monoxide now carbon monoxide is a
particularly nasty poisonous gas and
what it does is it stops red blood cells
from being able to carry oxygen around
your body so it's a really poisonous gas
and if you inhaled too much of this it
can cook can kill you because you your
body's tissues can't get any oxygen
burning fossil fuels also releases so2
also known as sulfur dioxide and this
causes acid rain that's when this
sulphur dioxide reacts with water in
clouds and then the rain produced is
actually type of sulfuric acid and this
could be really damaging for tree
for buildings and statues and if it gets
into lakes it can also cause a big
damage to those ecosystems so you can
see there's lots and lots of problems
with fossil fuels so if we have a look
at hydrogen fuel cells we only have
water as a waste product this looks
amazing because we won't have any of
these other problems associated with
burning fossil fuels also it's much more
energy efficient because we don't have
any moving parts like for example in a
fossil fuel power plant we've got to
have a turbine which turns and a
generator at all of these different
stages we have the potential to lose
energy so this is actually really energy
efficient our hydrogen fuel cells so
what's the problem why aren't they
everywhere right now so the big problem
kind of lies in hydrogen because
hydrogen is a gas it's takes up much
much more volume to store and so it's
much more difficult to store all so if
you remember from doing squeaky pot
tests in class if we set fire to
hydrogen we know that it's highly
explosive so we have an issue with
hydrogen being difficult to store and
being very explosive the other problem
is where do we get the hydrogen from now
currently lots of the hydrogen actually
comes from fossil fuels itself so it
doesn't really get rid of the problems
associated with fossil fuels also the
other way of doing it is through the
process of electrolysis so remember
electrolysis means using electricity to
separate now by using electrolysis we
actually still need to use a lot of
electricity and buy most of the work the
way that we currently generate
electricity in the UK is from fossil
fuels so we're still using fossil fuels
to get hydrogen either way we look at it
so just the summarize fuel cells
could be a written well it produces much
fewer waste products and harmful waste
products compared with fossil fuels it's
very energy efficient because it doesn't
contain any kind of moving parts to
generate this electricity but the
problem is hydrogen is extremely
difficult to store because it's a gas or
takes up a large volume anyway it's
explosive which can cause which is
obviously dangerous and finally to get
the hydrogen we kind of rely on fossil
fuels because if we using electrolysis
this requires electricity and a lot of
the electricity we generate in the first
place comes from fossil fuels Thanks